hey 42 here potatoes are one of the most
popular crops in the world and for good
reason they're easy to grow they're
cheap delicious and you can put them
into a spud gun to shoot people without
getting arrested but the simple Spud
that's sequestered in your pantry right
this moment can be a silent killer I'll
tell you why later in the video but
first I want to ask you when was the
last time you feared for the supply of
the food on your table or in your
Supermarket aside from Co of course when
Janice would have decapitated you in ale
3 over a
broccoli most of us don't have to fret
these days but there was a terrible time
in our history when people were forced
to eat rotten potatoes because it was
the only food they had why you'll soon
find out because this is the horrifying
story of how the humble Spud was
responsible for 1 million deaths over
just 7
years surf shark VPN keeps you safe and
private by covering up everything you do
online and surf shark VPN lets you
travel the world virtually by changing
your virtual location or whilst you are
physically traveling surf shark also
lets you connect via your home country
so you don't miss out on all your home
Comforts such as streaming video content
from home that might be blocked whilst
you're traveling there are over 3,200
servers in 100 countries so anywhere you
go you'll find a server that fits your
needs Ser shock VPN also offers a
multihop feature so you can put two VPN
servers between you and your online
destination for even more privacy and
security and I really love surf shar's
IP Rotator feature which constantly
changes your device's IP address without
losing your VPN connection it's really
important to stay safe online when
you're out and about and that's why I
use surf shark VPN so I can for example
access my online banking safely even on
public Wi-Fi which is something I would
never do without a VPN VPN also keep
your location and download history
private so you can send and receive
files securely quite simply Sur shock
VPN is an essential tool and make sure
you don't miss this exclusive holidays
deal by using the Code 42 you will get
up to six additional months for free all
you have to do is click the special link
in the description below don't miss out
and a big thanks to Sur shark for
sponsoring this video you've probably
heard of the Irish potato Fint of 1845
but there are still lots of questions
surrounding the tragedy what caused it
why couldn't the iris just eat something
else and most importantly of all could
it happen again perhaps to you and I
stay with me and by the end of this
video you'll not only understand the
tragic history of the Potato Famine but
also how today's agricultural practices
could be setting us up for a modern-day
disaster the potato is native to the
Andes Mountains of South America where
it was first domesticated over 7,000
years ago it was a staple of the incor
people who ate it boiled mashed and
stewed when the Spanish arrived in South
America in the 16th century they quickly
realized the potato was one of the most
important crops in the region and
brought it back to Europe with them but
the potato is initially viewed with
suspicion and disdain by European
Society especially the upper class who
post Renaissance thought of themselves
as rather important and civilized folk
and enjoyed nothing more than looking
down on the rest of the world in their
dirty Foods as they casually entertain
themselves with I don't know fencing and
the occasional spanking behind the rose
bushes however as a couple of hundred
years passed some started to identify
the potato's importance as a food staple
especially for the working class A
Series of PR campaigns by some of
Europe's Most fashionable figures soon
shot the sput into stardom specifically
Queen Marian tette of France who wore
potato Flowers in her hair to promote it
there was also a famed friend Chef
antoan Augustine pmena who was
absolutely obsessed with potatoes to the
point where it got a bit weird he held
lavish dinners attended by the upper
class and royalty where every damn dish
with some variation of potato including
his namesake pmena potatoes those
delicious little cubes tossed with
butter and herbs as the potato grips the
continent it proliferated in Ireland
some say it was Sir Walter rally who
first introduced it but however it
arrived on these ver Shores they went
absolutely nuts I mean potatoes for it
so why did the Irish and the potato
become instant BFFs well the conditions
there are potato perfect island is full
of lomy soil a sand silt clay mixture
that's ideal for spuds it also enjoys a
temperate climate with heavy rainfall
but most of all Island and the 17th 18th
and 19th centuries was a poor Nation
Under the grip of the British Empire it
was used as a bread bath basket oats
barley livestock and dairy were all
produced under the patronage of wealthy
remote English landowners and well you
guessed it exported to
England and so the peasantry had to make
do with whatever scraps were left over
it's no wonder they turned to the potato
it has a much higher yield per acre than
many other crops and was therefore the
perfect choice even a small plot of land
could sustain a family potatoes are
packed with essential nutrients like
vitamin C B6 and potassium the potato's
ability to sustain human life with
minimal effort was a game changer for
the first time in history a single acre
of land could be used to feed a family
of six for an entire year in the 19th
century the average Irishman was
consuming about 5 kilog of potatoes
every day I know that sounds like a
gross exaggeration but it isn't bear in
mind that most adult males were
performing huge amounts of physical
labor so they needed more sustenance the
crop accounted for 90% of most people's
diets as you might expect this led to a
population boom in Ireland and by the
time the 19th century rolled around up
to 8.5 million people lived on the
emerald aisle this huge population was
entirely dependent on the potato for
sustenance and so they grew it on a
massive scale in fact the Irish Reliance
on the potato was so extreme that the
country was effectively a
monoculture that that's when a single
crop is grown over a large area of land
and as you'll soon see that was a very
dangerous thing to be it's like putting
your whole life savings on a single
horse it could be a winner but it could
also its face on the Starting Gate
and break its nose in the early hours of
a summer day in 1845 in County Waterford
an Irish peasant noticed the leaves of
his potato plants had turned a yellowish
Brown so he dug them up to investigate
and what he found shocked him too his
core the potatoes were black and rotten
and covered in strange lesions they
emitted a foul odor he didn't know it at
the time but the worst chapter in
Island's history had just
begun specifically a potato fungus
called fop infestans had arrived on a
ship we don't know from where exactly
but the disease had been reported in
Belgium earlier in that year and we
think it arrived there from North
America where it had been spotted as
early as 1840 we suspect it probably
originated in Mexico or the Andes after
hitting Island its spread was rapid by
the end of the year most of the crops in
the country had been infested across the
rest of Europe people grew many
different varieties of potato but almost
every potato crop in Ireland was of one
single variety The Irish lumper because
of its very high yield trouble was the
lumper was particularly susceptible to
the blight the impact was devastating in
the first year alone the blight wiped
out about 40% of Island's potato crop
that was bad but it wasn't enough to
cause widespread death and starvation
the country had experienced bad potato
Harvest before and it had always been
able to import other crops to make up
for it but the following year in 1846
the entire potato crop was wiped out but
nothing could have prepared this already
suffering Nation for what happened the
following year often called Black 47 for
reasons that will be come clear 1847 was
the most catastrophic year of the Irish
Potato frament by now the nation was
reeling from two years of failed
harvests their food reserves were
exhausted their hopes were exhausted
they were exhausted the population
density was Skyhigh and when the potato
crops failed there was no food to be
found anywhere people were eating grass
Nestles and seaweed just to stay alive
you may be wondering why they didn't
just eat the rot and potatoes they're
still calories after all well from our
plus 21st century perspective that might
seem like an option orbe it terrible but
I'm willing to bet not many of us have
ever tried to eat a large quantity of
rotten food for a start the smell and
taste of rotten potatoes was reportedly
so bad it would make the majority of
people instantly vomit even as they were
being dug out of the ground also when a
potato rots the majority of its
nutritional value is lost so eating it
is pointless
eating them made people so violently ill
they would lose more calories than
they'd gain and lastly eat enough rotten
potatoes and you'll just straight up die
from toxicity poisoning remember at the
start of the video I said that potatoes
can be a silent killer even the non
blighty potatoes that are in your
cupboard well it's true have you ever
noticed those green patches that develop
on slightly old potatoes that's a toxin
called solanine in small doses it causes
headaches and nausea but eat enough and
you'll experience hallucinations
paralysis and in extreme cases death
lacking decent food across the land mass
malnutrition set him typhus dentry and
Cera claims the lives of many that's if
they didn't die from starvation first to
make matters even worse landlords
started evicting peasants from their
homes because they couldn't grow
potatoes to earn their keep countless
people were turfed out into the cold
harsh soil that by now had found every
possible way to destroy their souls it's
estimated that up to half a million
people died during 1847 alone so why
didn't people start growing go crops
when the potato started to fail after
all this was the third year without a
harvest well most Irish citizens only
had a small plot of land and as
previously mentioned there are few crops
that can be grown so abundantly and feed
a whole family like the potato can and
it would have taken months to Source
alternative seeds that's if they had the
resources to do so which they didn't
then they would have had to prepare the
land and wait until the following year
for those seeds to bear fruit if they
did at all also most of the land in
Ireland was owned by absentee English
land and gentry and they held strict
rules about what the Irish could grow on
their land those rules were basically
potatoes to feed the Irish and
everything else like grain had to be
exported of course during the famine
Island was under the charge of Britain
the most powerful country in the world
at the time so they obviously sent help
immediately to alleviate the iris of
their
woes yeah not quite Britain's response
to the famine was slow and ineffective
and has since been the subject of great
criticism and it's easy to see why at
the end of 1845 British prime minister
Robert Peele ordered a bulkload of cheap
corn from America to send to Ireland
often referred to as Peel's Brimstone
but it didn't arrive until the following
year and when it did it was all hard it
required grinding to be made into food
which much of the Irish populace didn't
have the tools to do it was also less
nutritious than potatoes and all of the
Corn arrived into coastal towns so it
never actually reached the interior of
the country where the famine was hitting
the hardest the British also set up the
Public Works program in response to the
famine which offered employment to
impoverished Irish so they could buy
food but it was all pretty bloody
pointless they were primarily tasked
with Building Bridges and Roads that led
to places of little important s or were
already well connected it was all very
reminiscent of Victorian workhouses when
the inmates were made to pick the fibers
from old ropes not because it needed to
be done just because the Public Works
program also had another major flaw well
two actually firstly the wages were
extremely low barely enough to support a
family and secondly the work was
grueling and physically demanding so the
workers would burn off a huge amount of
calories and would have to purchase even
more food to survive them before having
said all this it's often reported that
the Public Works program was the most
effective relief effort of them all
during the famine at least those that
came from the British but even if it did
do good in some places it was abolished
in 1846 when British prime minister
Robert Peele was replaced with Lord John
Russell who unfortunately had little
care for the plight of the Irish and did
even less to help them peel the cold hor
truth was that many of the most
influential people in high British
Society
didn't want to help the Irish at the
time Britain's official Economic Policy
was La Fair which meant they left
markets to run their own course with
minimal intervention believing Only the
Strong should Prosper it was like
capitalism on crack also there was a
feeling among some of the more unsavory
types in Britain that the Irish were an
impure race and the famine was basically
a punishment from God for their Catholic
sins remember Britain was predominantly
Protestant at this point particularly in
the South a British civil servant
Charles travan who was largely in charge
of the relief efforts is infamously
known for saying that the famine was an
quote unquote effective mechanism for
reducing Surplus population and a
judgment of God lovely
guy with the British providing as much
help as a chocolate teapot to sooe the
alink nation the Irish took it upon
themselves to find a way out during the
famine over 1 million Irish fled the
country making Moses and his Israelites
look like bloody amers the majority
immigrated to America but Irish
communities were established all over
the world from Australia to Argentina
the great immigration had a huge impact
on global demographics and is one of the
reasons why so many people outside of
Ireland claim Irish heritage to this day
but for many even though they were
starving to death the decision to leave
Ireland wasn't an easy one at the start
of the famine passage to America cost
between £3 to5 which Was Out Of Reach
for most families but as it progressed
and the masses grew increasingly
desperate to leave some ship owners
lowered the price to between one to2 but
there was a catch they had to live in
steerage for the entirety of the
grueling 8 week Voyage this was to hold
of the ship where conditions were dim
Grim crowded and extremely unsanitary
most would be forced to sleep sandwich
between others like sardines on planks
of solid wood hence these famine ships
eventually became known as coffin ships
the mortality rates were as high as 20%
with most dying from typhus or ship
fever as many called
it even after the famine had subsided
the immigration from Ireland continued
in great numbers before the famine the
population of Ireland was 8.5 Million by
1960 after Decades of continuous
immigration the populace had dipped all
the way to 4.4 million in fact as if
writing this video Ireland has only just
surpassed 5 million once again which is
obviously still well below its
pre-famine numbers this is in stark
contrast to most other nations that have
seen surging population numbers since
the 19th century the effects of the
famine changed Island in a way that few
other world events ever have for any
other single
nation and it wasn't just the population
that changed everything did for example
the famine is often blamed for wiping
out the Irish language well not entirely
but it certainly made a noticeable dent
in its usage how well to put it rather
morbidly the famine killed most of its
speakers the west and south of Island
were the hardest hit by the famine and
they also happened to be where the Irish
language was most dominant and the
millions of others who emmigrated mostly
did so to English-speaking countries
where they no longer had much need for
their native tongue after the famine
there was also a stigma surrounding the
Irish language many of the job
opportunities that emerged were for
English employers or English companies
who demanded their Irish employees speak
English not
Irish so forgoing the Irish language and
replacing it with English was seen as a
means to upwards economic and social
Mobility this was unfortunately echoed
through the Irish school system after
the famine some schools would punish
their pupils for speaking Irish instead
of English although it has seen a bit of
a Resurgence in recent years with Irish
language lessons now being a compulsory
school subject in the Republic of
Ireland however the amount of active
daily speakers remains very low it's
about 2% today whereas in the 1800s it
was about
40% if there's a major lesson we can
learn from history it's that great
progress is often born from great
tragedy and although the famine was
devastating to Ireland it did teach both
Ireland and the rest of the world the
importance of diversification in
agriculture or more accurately it taught
us the dangers of
monocultures an entire country was fed
on a single strain of a single crop
after the famine Irish Farmers started
to diversify moving away from the doomed
lumper they planted a range of blight
resistant potatoes grains and other
crops are also grown to supplement the
new
diet but here's another lesson for you
history is often doomed to repeat itself
the global population has exploded since
the 19th century and you'd think that by
now we'd have put safe guards in place
to protect us in case another crop
blight emerges from the dark corners of
Mother Nature's poisonous Locker after
all a large scale blight that we can't
stop that could Target corn wheat or
rice wouldn't kill a million like in
19th century Ireland it could kill in
the magnitude of a hundred times more
potentially hundreds of
millions but here's a cold sobering
reality for you today the world is more
reliant on monocultures than ever before
in history history in the 1840s Ireland
was the only country that relied on the
lump of potato today we have a range of
monocultures that the entire planet
depends on for example more than 90% of
the world's soy is grown in just four
countries America Brazil Argentina and
Paraguay and if you think that's bad
consider this 75% of the world's
chocolate well cocoa is grown in a
single area West Africa all of which
means that if a new strain of blight
were to wipe the world's soy chocolate
crops it would make the Irish Potato
Famine look like a blip and there have
already been scares when it comes to the
world's most eaten fruit bananas
worldwide banana production is a
monoculture pretty much all commercially
grown bananas are of the Cavendish
variety but it's susceptible to Panama
disease and there have already been
countless outbreaks in recent decades
and even in modern times potato blights
are still causing chaos in 2007 a new
strain of blight wiped out much of the
potato crop in Britain and Ireland and
for a while it looked like history might
be about to repeat itself thankfully the
response was Swift and the effects were
limited but there's no guarantee we'll
be so lucky next
time the good news is this is a problem
we can do something about we can't
control the weather but we can change
the way we Farm by diversifying what we
grow and what we buy we can all reduce
our Reliance on monoc cultures by eating
a more varied diet and we can all try to
buy more food that's grown locally so if
there is a problem with the global food
trade we won't be as heavily impacted so
let's learn our lesson from the blight
of the Irish and not let the ghosts of
famine past haunt us in famine
future thanks for watching